[Musique]
il y a trois mois le maréchal pétain
renvoyé par hitler venait se livrer à la
france à la frontière suisse le général
koenig prenait livraison de celui qui
avait profité de notre défaite pour
supprimer la république d'un trait de
plume
il y a trois mois pétain toujours
entouré d'une garde personnelle là mais
d'une garde un peu particulière cette
fois rentré en prison après montoir
montrouge
[Musique]
celui qui s'était fait nommer chef de
l'état allait commencer derrière ces
sombres muraille
le dernier chapitre d'une longue vie
[Musique]
après l'ambassade de madrid après
l'hôtel du parc après le château de
sigma ring game
cette année deux pièces nues du
prisonnier où pétain solitaire l'année
pu s'entretenir avec ses avocats et ses
souvenirs les premiers chargé de le
défendre les seconds de l'accusé et
maintenant c'est le palais de justice
et c'est la voiture cellulaire
pendant son procès pétain sera logé sur
place derrière ses fenêtres murées tout
exprès dans cette petite pièce installé
pour lui dans le palais de st louis au
coeur de paris à s'ouvrir un débat
immense lourdes conséquences
un débat que le pays opprimés tromper
attendait depuis cinq ans
et voici que pétain entre dans la salle
de la première chambre propre petite
salle pour un si grand procès pour ce
procès au l'homme qui osent encore se
dire chef de l'état va répondre des
années pendant lesquelles la france a
été occupé occupé aussi par le vide des
témoins sont là messieurs albert lebrun
louis marin paul reynaud michel
clemenceau et voici la cour qui va juger
avec 24 jurés tirés au sort parmi des
parlementaires et des hommes de la
résistance
le procureur général mme orneck
remplaçant face de l'accusé contre qui
il va mener la tâche
le premier président mon niveau ouvre
les débats par les questions rituelles
et l'accusé répond c'est un philippe
maréchal de france et tout de suite le
bâtonnier payen avocats de péta dépose
des conclusions pour refuser la
compétence de la haute cour de justice
conclusions qui seront rejetées
puis après lecture de l'acte
d'accusation le maréchal pétain lien
texte
un dernier message par lequel il déclare
qu'il ne répondra à aucune question
qu'à cela ne tienne puisque l'accusé se
réfugie dans le silence
on ne déposera pas de question et voilà
tout mais les avocats s'anime soulève de
nouveaux incidents le ton s'élève le
procureur général morlaix réplique la
barbe en bataille le geste véhément
bondissant sous les allusions personnel
la cave elle devient plus vivre la salle
est houleuse
enfin le calme est rétabli et devant
pétain qui lui jette un coup d'oeil en
piller monsieur paul reynaud vient
déposer le premier l'ancien président du
conseil explique pourquoi et comment il
a lui même appelé pétain au pouvoir les
souvenirs affreux de 1940 reviennent à
quoi pensent ce vieillard que la
république combla d'honneur et qui
déchira la république
pense-t-il à ce jour où il serrait la
main d'hitler il faut continuer la
france avait besoin de répondant
pense-t-il à ce jour il serrait la main
d'hermann göring le plui deux de nos
ennemis dans la salle de la première
chambre
le procès pétain se poursuit semaine des
témoins d'achat jusque edouard daladier
évoque les souvenirs cruel et honteux de
la guerre de la débâcle et de
l'armistice monsieur albert lebrun
rappelle les journées tragiques de
bordeaux où les chefs militaires ne
pensait cannes plus bas et où se
heurtait les thèses de l'espérance à
tout prix et de l'abandon à tout prix ce
que janot n'est président du sénat
apporte son témoignage sur cet homme il
ne se fit renaître de pouvoir que pour
en abuser aussitôt puis c'est monsieur
louis marin qui affirme avec énergie que
l'armistice
[ __ ] déshonorant manquement à la
parole donnée et monsieur léon blum
évoque la grande peur de vichy qui
ajoutait la honte à la défaite avec
monsieur michel clemenceau c'est un peu
de la grande voix du tigre qui se fait
entendre dans ce débat houleux général
doit ya bien accusé à son tour le
président herriot témoigne dans ce
procès où l'on juge un homme dont la
carrière va de verdun à montoir dans ce
procès où le principal témoin c'est la
france entière vaincu trompé et trahi
le procès continue monsieur marcel paul
résistant et déporté vient de lui rendre
son vrai sens en affirmant au nom de ses
camarades la responsabilité de pétain
dans la répression du patriotisme
français et c'est l'heure des témoins à
décharge
voici d'abord maxime weygand général
d'armée prisonniers en traitement au val
de grâce
ils attaquent vivement les assertions de
monsieur paul reynaud touchant
l'armistice et pétain rompant son
silence à pau ce départ amène à la barre
mais chez paul reynaud que la querelle
de l'armistice tu met immédiatement aux
prises avec les deux chefs d'armée
querelle à laquelle se mêle bientôt
avocat et procureure générale témoins
des charges encore voici le général
georges commandant du franc nord-est en
40 qui brosse un tableau de la campagne
de france
mais un témoin nous on va pouvoir être
entendue une vraie vedette cette fois
rien moins que pierre laval remis par
les américains aux mains de la france il
y avait longtemps que les français
n'avaient pas revu cette figure sinistre
des mauvais jours laval l'avocat des
mauvaises causes va plaider le dossier
peta le procès péta dit il c'est un peu
le mien et c'est le sien en effet pétain
laval les deux noms sont liés liés par
l'assassinât de la république lié par
toulon par la déportation les cours
martiales liés par vous rennes vallée
d'arrats au liés par laborde et patriote
liés par les fameux mots qui ont fait la
gloire misérable de bichi je souhaite la
victoire de l'allemagne
le procès s'achève le défilé des témoins
s'épuise
quelques vedettes encore parmi lesquels
peyrouton qui fut ministre de
l'intérieur et d'autres visages
maintenant les plus sinistres le trop
fameux de brienon qui avec ses manières
d'escrocs monde assure le jury de son
accord total avec pétain et ni le fameux
double jeu et voici darnand le tueur
l'homme de la milice
l'assassin des patriotes est la timide
comme un garçon boucher qui se sent les
mains rouges il s'asseyait à la table
des ministres auprès du maréchal pétain
qui n'ignoraient rien de lui ni son
accord avec hitler ni son activité
criminelle et c'est l'heure du
réquisitoire le procureur général mort
mais qui fut le lieutenant mornet du
temps de clemenceau requiert pour pétain
la peine qu'ils repéraient pour les 13 à
l'autre guerre d'abord tour à tour mais
prise au rni m le maire et le bâtonnier
payen présente les dépenses de celui qui
fut le maréchal pétain
c'est l'heure des jurés pendant les
longues audiences de ce long procès ces
hommes ont entendu se découvrir se
développer expliqué le cas à pétain
c'est à eux maintenant de parler pétain
est il coupable quel sera le sort de
pétain
les jurés ont parlé oui pétain est
coupable oui pétain mérite la mort
[Musique]